y
avance informativo en france 24 gracias
por estar con nosotros mi nombre es juan
pupiales cuando falta un poco más de 48
horas para la fecha límite de la
retirada de las tropas internacionales
en afganistán estados unidos anunció que
avanza la salida de los menos de 4000
efectivos con los que cuentan en el
aeropuerto de kabul la jornada de este
sábado ha estado marcada por las
tensiones con disparos al aire en los
alrededores de la terminal aérea y horas
después la respuesta de washington
contra el estado islámico quienes habían
reivindicado el atentado del jueves que
dejó hasta 170 fallecidos según fuentes
afganas de acuerdo con el pentágono sus
bombardeos provocaron dos bajas
importantes entre estos terroristas y
astrid western force es parte de ayer
las fuerzas militares de eeuu llevaron a
cabo una operación antiterrorista contra
un planificador y facilitador del estado
islámico de afganistán el ataque aéreo
se produjo en la provincia de nangarhar
en afganistán puedo confirmar a medida
que ha llegado más información que 2
objetivos de isis de alto perfil
murieron y uno resultó herido
en westwood
seguimos en medio oriente y vamos hasta
irak que acoge este sábado una cumbre
regional que encabece presidente francés
en manuel macro con el objetivo de
calmar tensiones en la región y
encontrar un punto de diálogo
acompañado de representantes de arabia
saudita e irán macro me hizo un llamado
a no bajar la guardia frente al grupo
estado islámico ya que dice siguen
siendo una amenaza especialmente en irak
el mandatario también afirmó que las
tropas galas permanecerán en este país
sin importar lo que haga eeuu lo
escuchamos
eric usuario americano no importa qué
decisiones tomen los estadounidenses
nosotros mantendremos nuestra presencia
en irak para luchar contra el terrorismo
entre los grupos terroristas permanezcan
operativos y el gobierno iraquí
soliciten nuestro apoyo aquí
mientras tanto desde irán el líder
supremo alí jamenéi se refirió al
acuerdo nuclear de 2015 y expresó que
las demandas políticas de washington a
teherán durante el gobierno actual del
presidente estadounidense joe biden no
han cambiado cuando en cuanto a las de
la administración de su predecesor
donald trump
toda la terapia de ryan y a la actual
administración de eeuu no es diferente a
la anterior lo que significa que lo que
quieren de irán con respecto a asuntos
nucleares es lo que trump quería en ese
entonces los que estaban en el poder en
el gobierno decían que es imposible que
es irracional hoy quieren esas mismas
cosas nada ha cambiado trump lo dijo de
una manera y ahora ellos lo están
diciendo de otra manera hubo ya eslabón
cambiamos de tema el sureste de eeuu
espera el impacto de ida que avanza por
el cuerpo de méxico como huracán de
categoría 1 y amenaza con ser
extremadamente peligroso cuando toque
tierra en la unión americana esto está
previsto que ocurra a lo largo de esta
noche de sábado y la madrugada de este
domingo con el estado de luisiana bajo
alerta por un aumento del nivel de las
aguas por la cosa pacífica la alerta es
para méxico ante la eventual llegada del
huracán ahora también de categoría 1
este fenómeno presenta vientos de 128
kilómetros por hora y se espera golpe de
colima nayarit y jalisco
hablamos de la pandemia de kobe 19 en
europa miles de personas marcharon en
berlín la capital alemana para protestar
contra las restricciones destinadas a
limitar la propagación de la pandemia
eso a pesar de que estas manifestaciones
se encuentran prohibidas es una
situación similar a lo que ocurre en
parís francia con el pase sanitario se
trata de una de las cuatro marchas
previstas en la capital gala por séptimo
fin de semana consecutivo contra las
medidas para contener la propagación de
esta pandemia y que ha impuesto el
gobierno francés
entretanto australia sigue registrando
unos números récord de contagios por
kobe 19 en las últimas 24 horas se
reportaron mil 126 casos siendo nueva
gales del sur cuya capital es sídney el
epicentro del nuevo brote causado por la
variante delta
pese al aumento de contagios las
autoridades locales de ese territorio
están evaluando a bill aliviar algunas
de las restricciones las próximas
semanas después de varias
manifestaciones contra estas medidas
frente a la pandemia
creencia porque hay más y mucho más en
324 mientras 24 puntocom